- Welcome back everybody.
We have Daniel Radcliffe and
Jane Krakowski on the line.
They are both actually in the new
"Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt:
Kimmy vs. the Reverend"
now on Netflix.
Go and check it out.
Because the new Kimmy Schmidt episode
is about making choices,
and because Twitter
forces tough questions upon us everyday,
Daniel, Jane and I are going to deal
with some of those very tough choices
in a little segment called:
"Kelly's Quaran-Twitter Questionnaire."
(high intensity techno music)
I'll read some of the most
liked and retweeted questions
on Twitter in the last month.
Then, we will all get to answer.
So, our first Twitter question
is from @theyearofelan.
"Your quarantine nickname
is how you feel right now
"plus the last thing you
ate out of the cupboard."
Okay Jane, you go, ladies first.
Go ahead.
- Oh. Okay.
Mine would be hopeful Nut Thins.
(laughs)
- That's amazing.
Daniel, what's yours?
- I was going to say,
mine I guess would be like
contented honey roasted almonds.
It's quite long.
(laughs)
- Oh, I like that though.
- Okay.
Mine is overwhelmed red velvet cake.
(laughs)
But you know what?
You usually do feel overwhelmed
when you eat too much of it.
A friend told me.
I obviously haven't eaten too much.
All right so next Twitter
question is from @GifMario.
"Who is your racer of choice
in Mario Kart on Nintendo 64?"
(gasps)
Daniel, what's yours?
You're the gamer.
- I was never very good at it,
but I think the character that I always
liked playing as the most was Yoshi.
- I love Yoshi!
- I think I would go for that
just cause he was like cute and fun.
- Yeah, Yoshi's cool.
That would have been mine.
Yoshi's mine.
What's yours, Jane?
Have you ever played Mario Kart?
- I've never played it.
I somehow did not get into
the video game thing at all
and I know with kids, the kid pressure
my son hasn't really gotten
into them yet either.
I'm sort of trying to slow that down.
But so, I'll take Yoshi too.
(laughs)
- Yoshi's awesome.
Yoshi's, it's a fun one.
This next one was posted
by @movingsideways.
"You are quarantined with the first artist
"you saw in concert, who is it?"
Daniel I'll let you go first.
- Well, the first band I
went to see was the Strokes,
which is quite cool,
but the actual real answer,
which is that a concert I was taken to,
when I was like 10,
would be the Pet Shop Boys.
So it would be me and the Pet Shop Boys.
- Wow! Those are both pretty cool.
- Yeah, they're both pretty cool.
- Yeah, okay, you're cool, whatever.
(laughs)
What was yours, Jane?
- Mine's a little more Jersey,
where I was raised.
My band is Van Halen.
- Oh, that's amazing!
- That would be a hell of a quarantine.
- So me and David Lee Roth like,
dancing on the table I guess, I dunno.
- Your quarantine's gonna be a good time.
That's amazing.
- My house is gonna be trashed.
(laughter)
- Mine, I honestly can't remember
I know this sounds funny,
I can't remember,
this is gonna sound funny,
but it was either the Toadies,
which is my favorite band of all time.
It's a Texas band, they're alternative.
Or it's Celine Dion, so
I don't know which one--
(laughs)
But I think she'd be a hell of a good time
in a quarantine.
- I think so too.
- I don't know if you've
seen her on stage,
but she's crazy funny.
But, okay, anyway.
Next question is from @cantedcat.
"Is it bad if I order five
pounds of Mike and Ike's?"
No it's not bad.
I mean, five pounds of it,
I mean, expect to gain a
good 10 after you eat it,
but yeah.
(laughter)
- We're all kinda buying
in bulk right now.
- Yeah, we are.
(laughs)
What would your candy of choice be
if you had only one candy
for this quarantine,
just curious?
- Uh.
- Oh my goodness.
- I know, I actually don't know my answer.
- Actually, Daniel will know this
'cause they are my favorite
and I actually-- this is embarrassing,
but they're Maynards Wine Gums.
- Oh wow.
- I love Wine Gums.
- What does that mean, what is that?
(laughs)
- It's hard to explain.
- They're like a--
- A Wine Gum?
- They're British.
- Yeah.
- We have a great British
store right near me
that imports stuff from Britain
'cause I love British
candy for some reason.
(mumbles)
- Yeah, so mine would be
Maynards Wine Gums, but that's so--
- Wine Gums are incredibly chewy,
but also somehow very hard.
They somehow manage to be both chewy
and hard to chew.
- You're kinda describing a Milk Dud.
- Yeah, but they're fruity flavored.
- It's more like a Gummy Bear, but harder.
- Yeah.
- Ohh.
- Mine would be
chocolate-covered Gummy Bears,
now I just thought of mine.
I love chocolate-covered Gummy Bears.
- I've never had that, is that good?
- Does that exist?
- You've never had
a chocolate-coated Gummy Bear?
- No.
- No, I've had regular
Gummy Bears a lot.
- I don't even like
regular Gummy Bears.
I just like the
chocolate-covered Gummy Bears.
I know that's weird.
Anyway, you're amazing and you're welcome
and I'm sorry.
(laughs)
- What would yours be, Daniel?
- I don't know, any kind of
tiny Mars bar or Snickers.
- Like the little bite-sized ones?
- Yeah, just want some of those
that don't feel like a full chocolate bar
that you can just hammer
away for hours. That.
- Yeah, I don't know
what that's like Daniel.
(laughs)
All right, well this last question
is from @jillyhendrix.
"Has anyone else moved on from wearing
"sweatpants and is now
just wearing blankets?"
(laughter)
What person is walking around their house
naked right now, that's awesome.
- I got sweatpants on,
I'm sweatpants gang.
- Oh, you're so good.
I was like, 'I feel weird
'not having shoes on
while I do an interview,'
so it's like--
- I love you, Daniel.
- I had to get dressed for this.
- It's still kinda snowy here in Montana,
and our place is on a ranch,
so I have full-on snow boots
and workout pants on that I'm
totally not gonna workout in.
- So I have a theory.
I've had a long-time theory that
you shouldn't wear sweatpants,
or you should wear clothes
that hurt a little bit
just to maintain your weight.
(laughs)
That's my only weight maintaining advice.
Not diet and exercise,
just wear something that hurts a little
so you remember not to overeat.
(laughs)
And it has gone to the wind.
I don't even wanna know how much weight
I've gained during quarantine
'cause I'm wearing sweatpants
and leggings everyday
- I know, when you wear elastic everyday
you just don't know, do ya?
- You just forget.
(laughs)
- Okay, well thank you so much.
Everyone, be sure to use
your time at home wisely.
And watch
"Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt:
Kimmy vs. the Reverend"
on Netflix, May 12th.
It's gonna be awesome.